EVERYBODY DO THE FLOP!
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Sumotori Dreams".
This game was made by the same guy that made "Goofball" only about two years back and somehow it's even silllier.
You'll see what I mean. Let's go.
Alright, now I want a good, clean fight. No funny business! Let's go!
Hep... Alright. Okay. OHHHH Whoawhoawhoa! Hey! Whoa! Whoa! Hey!
Do you like my flying squirrel kung fu style? No sumo have ever been able to stand up against me.
I haven't been able to stand up against me.
Slap fight! I'm gonna slap the piss out of you. Get out of my face! And I'm gonna fall over and die. Oh well
Could you get your face out of my butt, please? Thank you
Just doing my modern art here. My interpretive dance.
Coming for you, Brown! I'm coming for you, baby. Oh, I missed
Excuse me, pardon me, excuse me, pardon me.
Pardon me, excuse me, pardon me, excuse me.
Alright, let's go again. Come on. Bring it on! Bring it on! Bring it!
Whoa! Where did I go? I disappeared!
All that energy. All that fuss. All for death.
Thank you for fondling my butt.
Ho-zah! Hah! Ow. Why? WHOA!
Brown guy, ease it up there a bit. You're taking this a little too seriously. Oh, my-
Can I get an instant replay of that?
Hi, Green. Haha! What the Hell was I doing? Stop it, you're weird!
Come here, Brown. I'm gonna get you. I'm gonna get you.
YEAH! Yeah, what's up? Yeah, what's up? Yeah, what's up?
Oh, I just wanna hug you a little bit. I just wanna be friends!
Come over here so I can be your friend. Weeee!
I'm just patting your butt a little bit. Needed a massage, if you know what I mean.
What happens if you go off the edge? Uh-oh, I'm about to find out.
Oh! Oh, no!
I'm okay. I'll get up in a second. Just give me a moment.
I'm being dramatic.
Can anyone give me a hand? Please?
White is stuck. White is literally stuck.
Uh! If you guys could get me a hand? Ahh!
Oh, God. Don't you come near me! Don't you come near me!
I warned you! I warned you!
Ah, that's good. That's fresh. You've washed today, haven't you?
Uh, oh. Uh, oh. No! No! NO!
Now Brown guy wants a whiff of my booty. Come on. I'm ready!
Let's do this! Bring it o-oh crap. Okay. Alright. Okay.
Any minute now. Okay. Alright, come on. No!!
Isn't this a fun pile up? Brown, get back here. Stop spanking my booty and get on with it.
No, not me! Not me! Not me, you bastards! Not me!
Not me! Okay, I kind of killed myself there.
(singing) And I can't even stand!
Well, this doesn't quite seem fair.
Brown, you douche. You better stay away from me.
No! Goddammit! I didn't even go down the stairs!
You just straight-up killed me.
Bye, Green. Good job! You having fun?
Oh, this game is so ridiculous. Come here! I'm gonna get you!
Brown. Brown, what are you doing? Owie.
BROWN, NO!!!
Come on! I want a piece of you! I want a piece of you! I want a piece of-ow!
EVERYBODY DO THE FLOP!
Alright, so that was Sumotori Dreams. It wasn't bad. It was quite funny at the beginning.
But, like "Goofball", it gets old kind of quickly.
I mean, besides the physical comedy, there's not much game there.
But either way, if you want to check it out, the link to the website is in the description
Check out my video "Goofball", also down there.
Leave a "like" if you enjoy this video
And as always, I will see you! In the next video!
Bye bye!